yeah have you have you
made me so host yeah
right okay that's fine mate
i'll just move that up there
okay then good afternoon everybody uh
and welcome to all the people that are
watching us on youtube
hope you have a nice afternoon with us
and uh we'll we'll get started with the
agenda
apologies for absence mary chair no
apologies
right on to item two minutes of the last
meetings we've got
two um i think i'd better do them
one at a time because i don't know
whether everybody was here
for both of them so meeting on the
uh 18th of august
um pages three
two
three two to nine
um i'll go through i'll go through the
the pages page three
page four page five
page six page seven
page eight page nine
sure yeah yeah just for accuracy
page nine um it should read
environmental
social and governance not
environmental and social governance it's
environmental
social and governance
right which page nine are you talking
about steve
well it's page seven at the top and nine
at the bottom
right okay of the minutes it's the last
page
yeah okay can we make it
yeah i've got it i've got it coming
amend that memory
okay yep
okay uh proposer
can we have the vote mary yes chair
councillor bowton for
councillor cottle hankin or
mr dengate or
councillor cup for
council haims
unmute peter yeah sorry before
mr harper or
cancer range for
counsellor langford or
councillor manly i'm abstaining mary i
wasn't there yep
councillor newton four
and councillor watson oh
yeah that's ten for one abstention okay
thank you
right okay we're going now to uh
the meeting on the the special meeting
we had on the 15th
of september um
i'll read the pages up page 10
11 12
13. um
another proposal
i'll propose jude gob proposing
second that simon newton
all those in favor chair you've got
councillor cottle hankins hand up
all right sorry sorry i just wanted to
double check
at the bottom of page 13 about the
member grants that's from last year
isn't it
member grants and new homes bonus that's
right
it's it's the grants that did they under
spend for them
for the year before yeah not not for
this year's one
no no not for this year definitely not
for this year cheryl
i want my thousand pound back um
okay vote mary
yes chad councillor barton uh four
councillor carl hunking or mr dengate
or councillor cub
four council haims or
mr harper or
councillor inch
councillor langford for
councillor manly i'm abstaining again
mary i wasn't there
okay council newton four
and councillor watson four
there's ten four one abstention okay
thank you mary
we'll move on we'll move on to action
list page 14 and 15.
minute 69 that's still ongoing it'll be
ongoing for
quite a while i would think it's stephen
stevens are you in i am chair all right
okay um committee date
sent to july qb you've got councillor
hayes hand up
okay oh what are we on are we on page 15
sorry sorry action list is it did you
say
yes yeah i just wonder if you've got a
date for the um
task and finish group yeah yes we have
we'll come up later
thank you wait i i thought you'd
probably got the date actually
by email oh maybe i have sorry
okay um
minute eight then the torrington pannier
market property and procurement
manager third of august we've got
nothing on that at the minute qbr 420
1920 electric
car charging point fees off street
parking that's completed
okay yes yeah did you want a quick
update on the minute eight torrential
penny market one because i've had a chat
with adrian the property manager and
and he gave me a little bit of an update
on that one yes please sean
yeah so so the the works to the hoppers
has obviously been done
up there and he adrian says that he he's
provided some information to
to john um that he thought had been
circulated but obviously not um so the
hoppers
uh have been done that that they are as
large as they can be
and because of the physical constraints
of the buildings but what they've done
to alleviate the flooding problems is
divert the water
um any excess water to other places and
that seems to have
um stopped the flooding issues according
to adrian
at the moment the new lighting is done
and the painting of the front of the
penny market isn't on the agenda um we
don't have that in the program
and there's no intention to do that at
the moment so if you're happy with that
update i'd mark that as completed but
that's actually
okay well i'm happy with the update
everybody else happy with the update
or not if you if you if you don't want
to unmute
we'd obviously like to have it painted
but i'll bring that up a separate time
all right cheryl okay everybody happy
with that we conflicted
right a minute another minute eight
uh
cube br 490 electric car charging fees
um this would select senior solicitor
and this is ongoing so okay
um we on
to the one at the bottom to convene
meeting of income generation task and
finish group
you'll be pleased to know petra it's
tuesday the 13th of october
hello
oh
oh dear it's frozen oh frozen
i'm not frozen someone's frozen no i
think it's all fine
sure it's all fine i'm frozen
no you're not frozen we can we can see
you and hear you
yeah right i'll make it myself sorry
did you understand that peter yes thank
you chair
okay i can't remember the date but i'm
sure we'll you'll
you'll soon find out the the time rather
sorry
okay
i'll go on item four public
contributions
uh now we we have got
two speakers for the first one um
do we want to do the public
contributions
before we just before we get to item
eight
or well steve
where's he gone oh uh chad i'm still
here um i i guess the
items five six and seven i wouldn't
imagine there are
is very much for you to report there so
if you did the public contributions now
it would feed straight into
item eight almost anymore okay yeah okay
then
okay we'll go into uh the public
contributions i think we've got mr smith
yeah chair i'll just let mr smith and
judith gentry
judith all right okay she's going to sit
out all this thing is she
right
hello yeah sure they're both joined now
right hello mr smith
that's it right you've got your you've
got your three minutes now mr smith
okay hang on yeah okay i'll see you now
but look peter because of my stroke i'm
gonna let my
son-in-law who was also a director of
the company read it out for me because
okay
that's fine no problem at all
okay good afternoon uh so this is a
statement violent smith
in relation to a calling of a decision
by the cnr committee held back on the
7th of september
stacy has accurately described the
history of the site
of much debate accusations and chinese
whispers since torrey sold the site to
us for living limited some seven years
ago
accusations of corruption between myself
and officers have been made by both
members of the public and council
members concerning the purchase of the
site
all of which are entirely unfounded
despite miraculous detourage for an
inquiry into these accusations knowing
inquiry has ever taken
place since purchasing the site we have
spent over a hundred thousand
on planning and site works it has become
evident that a 15 bedroom hotel is not
viable because the site is too small to
accommodate the ancillary offices
required to run ahead
in addition despite torridge agreeing
the use of the public car park
it was later refused and car parking had
to be found on adjoining land owned by
western living
in effect this left the hotel site on
its own as being valueless
despite the above we tried to find
another developer
we were not successful as a hotel to be
viable required at least
30 bedrooms and this could not be
accommodated on the site without using
the public car parks
in addition the extra money required by
torres to vary the covenant
puts all our possible development
partners off
we made a request to remove the covenant
and offer the sum of 120 000 to turret
as compensation
this was considered at the cnr meeting
on the 7th september
when the vote was taken it was evident
that some of the councillors either did
not
or did not want to understand that the
land was already owned by my company
and the offer was not to buy anything
but to release the covenant that had no
other value to torridge
despite being continuously advised by
stacey some of the members could not
differentiate between
the purpose of the cnr committee and the
planning committee
some would not accept the independent
value obtained by the council
and some were wanting some sort of
uplift this evaluation confirmed that my
offer was in line
excuse me with a valuation where the use
would be changed to residential
there was some discussion as to what my
intentions are but nobody knew as i do
not know
myself yet once the covenant exists
it is not impossible to discuss any
alternative use
this year we managed to run a successful
curb compliant beer garden
attached to our pub and restaurant it is
our intention to repeat this next year
and then if possible
improve it by partially covering the
whole site with the see-through
retractable roof after that we'll have
to wait and see
the valuation was on the basis of
converting to residential
if the covenant is removed this cannot
be ruled out in the future if no other
viable idea comes forward
any development of this site will
require planning permission in the
normal way
agreement to remove the covenant does
not constitute planning approval
thank you thank you mr chairman
yeah thank you very much okay um
there's nobody else to speak on on on
this thing
no no no no right okay thank you very
much
okay just nip through item five then
decorations of interest you all
understand about the declarations of
interest
uh urgent matches uh i haven't got any
urgent matters
agreements between agendas part one and
two we've got no part two
okay we're going to number eight calling
the covenant for
the hotel site westward pages 16 to 21.
sean do you want to start by saying
anything
chair i think stacy has joined us for
that purpose today so
uh where is she oh yeah okay spacey
sure i wasn't expecting to talk because
it seems to be the
economy and planning manager reports so
well that that
he says that's what that's why i went to
him stacey and obviously
right councillor watson
i think we'll hand it over to the
planning and economy manager i'm happy
to answer questions if they
if they arise that's that's fine chair
so so i mean as as um
mr smith just talked about at the last
community and resources committee
uh an offer to uh to remove
uh to pay some money to remove the
restricted covenant on the hotel site
was debated and the report that
you have in front of you basically
summarizes that debate
the cnr report associated or that was
discussed
at that time is also appended
and then that was later subject to
calling from
various members that are listed in the
covering report
each with uh separate reasons for their
calling
uh ranging from that they didn't feel
that there was enough
scrutiny of the reasons for a refusal
through to the fact that they didn't
think that there was local public
objection
so in essence it was uh that that's it
there's nothing really very much further
to add
it's for you to scrutinize the decision
of community resources
not to remove the restrictive government
okay
fine okay then
we'll get a bit better get down to it
then
i have got an enormous list of people
here and nobody with their hands up who
wants to start
no first of all i'll i'll take that back
um
there's councillor mcgoffs here and
councillor kotlonkin
can you explain explain explain why what
your reason for calling is
dem up first thank you mr chairman
um i did actually email the council with
my details of the calling
and that's put my name down and my
reason to call this into your
committee is to for your community to
have a thorough look through this um
my missy 120 thousand pounds for the
covenant to be lifted
would be better off in torridge's
coffers
as in we could actually utilize this
money for the benefit wider community
as we are aware so far in westerville
there's we
found money for the slipway we found
money for the new car parking
we can't keep spending money right
replenishing the pot
this is a chance for us to get some
money back into the pot
now um it's been touched upon
the hotel sites already had planning
permission for so
it can go forward if the applicant wants
to do so
i don't think they want to proceed with
this at the moment so i don't say it's
going to affect the
uh in the public western whole but it's
already been approved it's not as if it
be developed like the monstrosity of
flats which has been left nearly dormant
for a decade
at the top now the restrictions of the
covenant on the land
well the applicants already own the land
and surely by releasing this covenant
we can produce a good capital receipt
hundred twenty thousand playing for
torres district council
you know i just can't see how by keeping
this covenant on
we can benefit the public that's orange
i just i just can't see it mr chairman
again i will feel free to turn in all
right sorry
i said if you want to speak me again
feel free don't worry i will do
all right good man that's what i like
yeah okay
cheryl hi yeah um
so i watched the debate on at cnr
and there were no public contributions
objecting to it
i've had no one come to me objecting to
it either
um so and it was really close
the debate but at cnr the vote i thought
it was going to go the other way
and then they voted opposite to what
they were sort of saying in the debate
so i thought it deserved further debate
it wasn't unanimous
it was a really close vote so i thought
it deserved further debate
at this committee by more councillors
what else is there oh i don't know if
there's actually a need for a hotel
in westwood here anymore or not a lot of
people seem to not actually want a hotel
there
so it makes sense to lift the covenant
and at the same time
we could use the money within torridge
it seems well yeah i just wanted it to
have further debate here
okay could i just bring steve steve can
he
or david david's the one really is that
is our acting 151 aren't you dave
yeah i have that pleasure yes this money
if
if this 120 000 pounds come on where
would it go to
it'd be a capital receipt and
so generally be used for capital
purposes just just for capital purposes
yeah generally you have to have a
special um to
keep it simple if you get a capital
receipt you need to spend it on capital
right that's fine mate so we just can't
go and spend it willy nilly anyway
well we do have a shortfall in our
capital programme um
it's the red into in red or something
a bit of a minus job so would just get
lost
in the capital it would be a
contribution towards our capital funding
yeah okay thank you right then
um who have we got now councillor inch
thank you chair and uh good afternoon to
everyone
um i was actually a coacher when
when we debated this about seven years
ago um
i do remember because i was served on
the cnr um
committee then excuse me
um and i do remember that um
putting this covered on there and i
think i've voted for it actually
um now there was concerns then
that if we didn't put a covenant on it
for a hotel only
that um something else was going to be
built there
that uh wasn't in line with with the
councillors thinking at the time
um times have changed we all know that
i would like to put if we can through
through the senior sister there
i would like to recommend something to
cnr
that might go down well with everyone
that we put another covenant on it
take this one off and put another new
covenant on it
saying that the land has got to be used
for commercial use only
because i think that uh as uh
derma as uh darling goth there comes
from gotham just said that i don't think
anybody needs
more um of those um
tall flats down there anymore and i
think
that may bear well with the community
down there if we said
that this has got to be for commercial
use
only and i i would like to make that
recommendation if i've got a secondary
chair okay yeah okay
we'll just we'll we'll we'll come back
to that tony
i've got some more ants up simon
i was gonna just ask on on that one just
to start with chad
can we do that saying we don't own a
lamb so can we actually go
applying new covenants on it i i'd i
would have thought not perhaps stacy can
um stacy can you come and clarify please
yes chair um we can do if if the
owner consents to that
um so i i suppose the difficulty that
recommendation can certainly be made and
that negotiation can certainly be had
with with the owner
um the evaluation that we have at the
moment is on removal of the covenant so
it would need another evaluation
potentially
it hasn't been valued on that basis at
the moment but we don't have to go
through that rigmarole now do it this
committee
no it wouldn't mean just a negotiation
chair with the owner
right anybody any any other member from
members
can i can i yeah you can carry on chat
yeah
please um
i'd like to just start by saying
um because i'm new to or still
relatively new to the council i have no
involvement in the site
or the personalities involved and as a
result i bring
no prejudicial baggage to the argument
right um as far as i see it an awful lot
of people
seem to be influenced or touched by some
of the individuals that are involved in
this along the way
um looking at it and therefore ignoring
the individuals
um and the history to a point and
looking at it
as it is now
i would like somebody to justify to me
the need for the continued requirement
for a covenant on that site
why are we saying what is the
justification
for saying that we can own or
only a hotel can be built there rather
than
any other form of development or use
at the end of the day the market will
decide
what is needed on that site together
with
the plans committee and they are the
ones who will regulate
whether it's appropriate for any
development
to go ahead there i wouldn't have
thought that it's a matter
for cnr but to to start with i
i think this all goes back to a very
simple question
and that is what is the justification
for
continuing with that covenant covenants
are always
time time sensitive or time life and
after a while
they often lose their relevance and then
it's time for them to be removed
as a matter of principle i would say it
is bad
to impose regulation and restriction
when it is not needed so
at the moment i am not convinced at all
by the cnr refusal to remove
it um and i would i want
somebody to tell me why it needs to be
there
i don't i haven't heard an argument that
remotely stacks up
as to why there needs to be a covenant
there's lots of other
natural things that will control it the
market
the planning committee uh etc um
and covenants personally i i think
should be used
very sparingly and very carefully and
um uh i'm not really sure you know this
is
distincts of people trying to keep
control of something when actually
they've sold it and
they don't have control but they want to
somehow keep their hand on it
uh which um i i don't like but um
uh i think somebody needs to justify why
it
needs to remain uh and in a in a factual
way not in an emotional way
okay stacy would you like to answer that
yes chad can do um and that was the deal
at the time
and that wasn't what was agreed by um
both parties i think
at that stage and we are going back a
few years now i think the sale took
place in 2014.
um the intention was to build a hotel
um and the owner was content with the
restriction
i i think as councillor newton has
alluded to
um time's moved on since that point um
he's saying and i don't i don't know
you know i'm not a commercial valuer but
he's saying that the hotel isn't viable
um and i suppose he's he's very
restricted now
um because um the site unless he can
build a hotel was gonna sit there do it
doing nothing effectively
so um the justification at the time was
that that was a
you know a willing deal between buyer
and seller um
but it's no longer viable and and that's
why he's seeking the removal
okay right
simon is that is are you happy with that
i i i thank stacy for for the
the um legal history on that which i
fully understand uh at the time um
i don't think it has any bearing
on continued justification now
as i said times have changed the
situation's changed and um
uh i cannot see that the council
has any need to
continue to insist that a hotel has
built that
um and um so uh yes i
i i agree with with stacey times have
changed and
i i don't see uh you know
where the justification is okay
okay anybody else want to speak on this
because nobody's got their hand up
so okay are you making a proposal to do
that simon
or well it looks
i i don't see an awful lot of people um
uh
offering anything different so yeah i
mean i i said as much of course
i stand by that yes so okay i mean
i i would um what would the proposal say
i mean the proposal
is to to remove the covenant
in in in the absence of of of
justification for its continued use the
the covenant should be removed right
okay
is there a second there for that i'm
happy to second that chair
is that you richard is his yes right
okay
go back to tony a minute tony you've
proposed
what i i propose that we recommend
that it goes back to seeing our
recommendation that we put a
new covenant on it take off the covenant
for the hotel
and put a cover up on there saying that
it's going to be for commercial use only
and that could mean anything from a pub
to a restaurant
to whatever so it's going to be used for
a commercial use only
not just the hotel okay is there a
seconder for that
okay you've got a couple of hands up
yeah
yeah i'll take you first
hello hi hello thank you do you wish to
hear from councillor hames as he sits on
your committee before i add
i yeah i'd prefer it
thank you chad i was just going to
second councillor inches proposal
all right okay fine so you've got a
seconder there
and you and you've got a second for
yours simon
okay claire you you give it a go well
thank you for allowing me to speak
i've previously refrained from
contributing to this debate
as a ward member for westwood ho however
today i know it's important not only to
represent the fine intro
financial interests of this council but
to represent the electorate of westwood
ho
and as such i'd like to ask for your
consideration of the following issues
i have as reported at the last meeting
of cnr
stated that whilst canvassing as a
prospective councillor
an overwhelming number of constituents
were opposed to plans for a hotel on the
square
the however in this is that the plans in
219
2019 when i was canvassing that were
being discussed were a huge
glittering multi-roomed hotel which
completely overwhelmed the site
and the community objected strongly to
these proposals
the proposal was not progressed any
further and as i
as i assume as a direct result of these
objections
i have not ever stated that i'm against
any
more acceptable hotel development and
would wish that to be noted
the original concept of hotel provision
in westwood was born out of the westward
home regeneration plan
and the site was sold with the covenant
as we've heard on the land for this sole
use
this was a condition of the sale many
years have passed and many applications
have sought approval
removal of the covenant has been
requested and refused
the covenant that is in place today
protects the land from any development
other than a hotel
once removed any future planning
applications
can be considered and in light of the
greatest overhaul of planning
that i've seen in my lifetime proposed
in the white paper
it would appear that planning
authorities will be unable to refuse
applications for intensive development
especially on areas previously
identified for regeneration
i may be wrong but there seems to be a
strong belief that this is the direction
that we will have to follow
finally i would suggest what i ask you
to consider
is whether a short-term benefit of a
capital receipt
which will go a small way to plugging a
shortfall in our capital programme
against potentially unencumbered
development
of a prime site and the impact this may
have on the community today
and tomorrow i've listened to the
proposals
from both uh are my fellow councillors
from councillor newton to lift the
covenant
as time has moved on and the second
issue
from councillor inch to
look at adjusting the covenant for a
development for commercial use only
commercial use it is part of the
development site
i think could be more appropriate but
to lift it entirely and to leave the
site unencumbered
i think will open the doors to um
bids for all sorts of developments and i
cannot see
in the owner's mind or his plans
but i just would like to point out that
we should retain
our covenant on this site until we have
clearer pictures thank you okay thanks
fred
all right i'll peter christie you can
have a go now come on
thank you um i'm not a member of the
committee but uh many years ago i was a
member of the asset management
and this was the one that first looked
at this site and whether it should be
sold or not
uh it's a prime site in westwood ho and
i have to say it was extremely
contentious when it came
up uh firstly the sale of it was
extremely contentious there was a lot of
fuss in westwood
as councillor hodson has identified uh
it was it has a very tangled planning in
history
which i wish some councillors would look
at the reason
it was the covenant was put on was
simply
because it was decided back then that
westwood home needed
some hotel accommodation
and it was put on partly to satisfy
uh people living at westwood ho who
didn't want to see that site
go for yet another huge block of flats
as councillor hudson had said
um councillor newton said that the uh
the market will control it
we've already seen what the market has
done down westwood hill it's basically
destroyed it
uh many years ago when i joined the
council i always remember the chief
planning officer at the time saying
westwood hose beyond redemption
um yes uh now you may think it's got
better personally i don't and a lot of
people don't
that's the reason the covenant was put
on
it was simply to help control the
situation
down there we don't know what will be
applied down there
the hotel was deemed necessary under the
local plan then under
uh local people and if you want to
change the covenant now
um i i really can't see any
justification for it the covenant was
put on it was agreed
i keep hearing times have changed really
i thought we were all going to have
staycations now there should be a huge
benefit to western homes i have a hotel
there
and i haven't i have yet to see i don't
know i haven't got the minutes in front
of me
i've yet to see what marketing strategy
has been
pursued to see if this could be a hotel
or not thank you
okay thanks well we've got two
i've got two proposals and seconders and
i think as tony uh
did his first we will take tony's first
um if nobody else has got anything to
say sorry chair
i'm just going to um it was councillor
um newton's that was proposed and
um seconded first so we'll have to
cancel sorry did um make the proposal
but it wasn't seconded until after
council newton's
yeah fine okay okay can i can i just say
something chair before we go further
yeah in the light of what's just been
said that i would just
um comment was made about the money
being issued
uh uh be been offered personally i don't
think the money
is is uh anything to do with it at all
i know councillor mcguff made up a
strong
uh statement for it but i don't think
the money in this case
is is the issue um
and really i mean what i'm saying is i
don't believe that
it's certainly this day and age um in an
area like this and if it was somewhere
stuck out in the middle of the country
then that might be slightly more
divisive
i don't think a covenant nor the use of
cnr
committee are the right tools to control
this site
um that that is that is the the job of
the plans committee and
and and that's how everybody else has to
um
um control that their sites etc so
i i stick by what i say that um
um i i don't like the the
the restriction on this i'm not sure
that i'm still not convinced that
anybody's offered
a viable justification
as to other than historic um
oh well that's what was negotiated on
the day fine
well we've been asked to reappraise that
now
today um not 15 or whatever years ago
and um i still don't see
um real justification as to
why we the council should be
controlling continuing to control what
can be done by
with somebody else's land other than
through use of the normal channels of
planning etc
so i stick by what i proposed thank you
okay simon thank you okay
we'll go to a vote on on mary are you
there
yes sir we'll go to a vote on simon's
proposal
okay councillor bowton
four councillor cottle hunkin
cheryl yeah it's really difficult one
i'm not sure i think i'll vote against
this one and four
councillor inches mr dengate
or councillor gabe
abstain
councillor haims against
mr harper abstain
councillor inch against
council langford against
councillor manly against
councillor newton
four and councillor watson i'm gonna
abstain
okay chair we have three four
five against and three abstentions
okay now we have to have tony's
we gotta go to tony's now i'm with stacy
yeah
yes chair yeah okay uh good
okay could we just refresh ourselves
with what tony's
um tony's is please
yes chairside should i just say that we
recommend to
cnr it goes back to cnr with the
recommendation that we
take off this covenant that's on there
now and put on another covenant saying
that
the land has got to be used for
commercial use only
okay okay uh
mary we'll take them take the vote okay
council about him uh four
councillor coddle honking or
mr dengate
councillor cub abstain
council haims or
mr harper abstain
council wrench for
councillor langford for
councillor manly or
councillor newton
i vote for but it would presumably also
require
the approval of the landowner yes
most definitely so it's not actually
just the council's shout
out you're right there
and councillor watson i'll go for
okay chair we have one
eight four one against and two
abstentions
okay so that that goes back to
cnr you know but stacy we're gonna after
well you and steve are gonna have to
uh get together with mr smith and see if
he agrees
which we can't do at this meeting yeah
well the chair the would have to have a
discussion with mr smith but it'll have
to go back to cnr
first of all to see if they'll accept
the recommendation
cnr have refused to move the covenant
and ons
recommendation is that um a new covenant
is put on for commercial use
only um so we'll have to see if c and r
agree of that recommendation
if c and r don't then it goes to full
council for full council to make that
decision
okay thanks stacy okay just to jump in
um chad that presumably also stacy would
require a revaluation
because if a new covenant is to be
placed on it then
obviously um there isn't a value to
that the landowner i would guess isn't
going to be
offered to offering to pay um the sun
that's been agreed
so i don't know that's true that's true
so it's what we've decided today is not
dead and buried okay
right as nobody else is going to
need to say anything on this one move on
yes
thank you thank you for coming mr smith
um
i'm sure you'll be be contacted
sooner rather than later
right top where are we tom
yeah where's tom i'm here
all right okay right
here we go then next item
calling for the burton art gallery
okay
um obviously before simon says anything
um i did i i called this
in and i called this in because
i i understand where david
david h comes from when he says we can
uh it is budgeted for the first year but
i'm just worried that
in the next preview the pre the next
years after
next year i don't know where we'll find
the money from
that's the problem uh for me
and that's why i would like us to
actually go through it and
see where see where the money's going to
come from or whether we can afford to do
it
cheryl you've got your hand up
yeah i just think council watson it had
unanimous support
at cnr um i really don't
i feel like we should go with their
proposal they bring so much
that the reason the thing with cnr is
they never discussed how we were going
to
to pay for it and and this has happened
a few times now with cnr
they don't discuss which they should
have gone through
that you know how we were going to to
pay for it where where the money was
going
to come from just don't forget we are in
a situation with a pandemic
even david doesn't know whether we'll
have enough money next year
and and so this is why it's come to to
to ons
and and i would hopefully hope
that in future when cnr gets things like
this
they do discuss it more as to to how it
can be afforded
but if we don't have places like the
burton it will have a net negative
impact on the economy and we will be
missing okay
you might be right cheryl you might be
right i'm not saying that they shouldn't
get anything i'm not saying that at all
in fact
i know judas gentry's on there in fact
this this report is the best report i've
ever seen
that the burton put together uh there
are a few questions about it but but
it's a very good
very good report but i'm not saying that
they shouldn't get anything
but what i'm saying is how do we keep
affording when we get tied into five
years
possibly six years
and it's no good thinking that 120 grand
from mr smith
will go a long way because that's going
into the capital and if that went if
that went in it could be lost straight
away
because we're we're in negative
anyway yeah i don't know whether
sean's got his hand to be maybe yeah
sean i was gonna
come to you first sean where are you
thank you chair um what i was going to
say was on on the 7th of september
when when i presented the reports to uh
to community and resources
and uh judith anthony and danby also
presented what the
uh the partner biddeford would provide
for the
proposed funding um we also appended
to that the the document under which
we operate so we for the last five years
have
worked under the terms of the service
and funding agreement
and the report that the the
recommendations that were put forward
and endorsed by cnr were that we
we set up a new service and funding
agreement so
one of the clauses in the existing
service and funding agreement is that
is that um we agree
we undertake to uh pay them for five
years
but that's subject to overriding
budgetary constraint
so that clause will go in the contract
will it
yes it was in the previous contract and
it would be again inserted into the next
service and funding agreement
so if there were a disaster
and we needed to review priorities that
gives us the provision to do that
right okay thanks sean uh councilman
if you want to say something although
you're not on this committee go on
well very much i'm not on a committee
but when i caught another decision you
know i i took the
integrity to joy and say why i did call
it in uh this is in my war to actually
import it to me
uh so i want to speak on this one and
quite rightly so
um sean county's alluded to the service
and funding agreement
cnr did look at this thoroughly to go
through and it is for the
officers to suggest where the money is
going to come from and advise the
councils of options
of where we can actually find the
funding from because as we're aware even
yourself chair
you have no input in today's their
day-to-day running of the council
where they're basically to support the
officers the best way we can so it's
there's them to find the finances and us
to agree whether we want to spend it or
not
so thank you much let me speak i'm in
full support of burton
if we could just cut the funding for the
burton then
council langford's new proposal coming
in for the racket center
well i'm pretty sure you can kiss that
goodbye counselor langford because they
won't support that either but i'm fully
behind you that as well thank you
i must admit one thing councilman mcguff
that the racket center has come in for
torridge to give
get them alone not
not take it out of our budget they're
going to find the money don't we
to loan anything but they would pay the
money back
and that's open to all of the public
attorneys end of financial loans
we're banking institution are we no
anyway castle langford
thanks very much uh just to say that i
completely agree with councillor cottle
hunkin um
uh and councillor mcgough actually um
the burton art gallery is an absolute
jewel
and we must do everything we can to
maintain it and encourage it etcetera
there seems to me to be quite
comprehensive for that
financial analysis in the original
report um
it was recommended that we were able to
make this contribution
and advise that we should um and
i think i respect the those conclusions
by the officers and i
um strongly agree with cnr's decision
thank you okay bye
jessica kotlunken yeah i just wanted to
add that torridge actually owned
the building and burton and we own
collections there
and so that makes it different to a lot
of other
um places where we award grants
this is an agreement they're running it
for us they're doing a fantastic job
doing it and i think we need to support
them and also
they're having less is still a lot of
money yes but it's less than what they
were receiving before
which is quite unusual and i think we
really need to support it
all right okay council of newton
yes cheryl but originally uh five years
ago
they said that by now they'd be standing
on their own feet and so
um this is actually all extra cash um
i i don't have a problem with with with
with the the principle that's been
approved
uh by cnr however just coming back to
what sean said
um i think it because it wasn't in the
original
brief and therefore people didn't
necessarily see that
although we did see it when um
ons external looked at the burton uh a
year ago
um which was the fact that year by year
um we could revise the funding if
necessary
i just think um it's i mean this is
discretionary funding
and we just don't know where things are
gonna go
um and you know we may well have a
squeeze where we
we just can't afford it so we've got to
have in very
plain language the ability
to vary what our commitment to the
burton
and to to say that um you know this is
good for five years or we're going to
review it in three so that suggests
that actually we're not going to look at
it until for three years
i think shawn though did say that there
is the get out
saying that we can um it is always
subject to affordability
um and um that just needs to be very
clearly stated
that um
we do um
hold the right to to change
the funding support in line with other
priorities if necessary
i think that's terribly important um
okay okay
julieth yeah thank you chair
um i just wanted to comment on something
that counselor newton had said
um there um there has never been any
indication councillor newton
that the charity would be
self-sufficient
and back through all of the work that
was done by the initial working group
back in um right back to 12 and 13
there was never there's any intention of
that so
i just needed to clarify that and i'm
sure that um
mr harper as the independent member who
was also on the original
uh burton working group before i do will
will also be able to endorse that as
will
the officers so i'm not sure whether
that may have come from that that has
uh i understand that councillor watson
uh back in 2017 was of that opinion and
i'm just looking at some minutes from a
meeting when that view was expressed
but at that meeting um sean um
you know reiterated that that that as
desirable and lovely as it would be
uh those um councillor newton it was
never the intention
thank you i i accept that and i
if that's the case i've been misinformed
and i apologize
for um making that statement when
obviously it doesn't stand
um whichever
we are in different very different times
and charted waters
from when this was all set up and we
must
retain the ability to be agile and
flexible
with our finances and to respond
to priorities changing priorities
perhaps uh
and although judith i fully accept that
you
you would not wish it so but i think
from a
from a council point of view we have got
to really keep
keep our options open um and this is an
aspiration
i very much hope that uh we can achieve
it um
but i think we've really got to leave
the door open as well
okay sean i'd like to just ask you
something sean
we started we started looking into
burton when
tilly was there that's right
yeah and we had the working group then
they started in 2014 the investigations
are different
i think mr arpa was on that working
group he wants to meet with jenny
etc and this was brought up
and that and what was agreed that after
five years
that the burden should be nearing
self to being self-sufficient and that
was and
that was never a minute admit uh meeting
but that's where that was discussed
heavily and that was
that's what should have been agreed now
whether
[Music]
by some means or other that he wasn't
agreed then okay
but i sat on them with those original
meetings
so let's let's not go any further
council kotlin i was just going to say
as well that the funding that we provide
for them also opens up
other sources of funding as a result
like
match funding type thing so it's not
like we're providing everything
for them no i understand that joe i
understand that
i was going to say you want sean to come
back yes please
sean thank you chair sorry i'm sorry
sean i
didn't realize you wanted to come back
no that's all right no problem at all um
so yeah you're absolutely right i mean
back in 2014 we started looking at a
whole range of options about how we
could better manage
and more efficiently manage and manage
for less money
uh the asset that is the burden a range
of options were looked into
and uh there was you know there was a
series of reports
presented at which we finally honed down
the preference to be to establish a
charitable trust
to move forward now as we then
progressed to the actual transfer
detailed business planning was put into
place
um you know we we looked into the what's
whys and wherefores of absolutely every
aspect of running the button
and we came down to the true costs
moving away from what might have been
some people's aspirations right at the
very beginning of the process
we got down to what was genuinely
achievable
and therefore following that um you
us members decided to establish the
charitable trust
and set up service and funding agreement
for a period of five years
with a third year review for
implementation of the sixth year so
let's
let's be let's be clear about that year
three doesn't mean you're changing what
happens in year four it means you start
looking at what happens in year six
of the agreement okay so when
when we started doing that it was it was
quite
clear to be honest that we couldn't
set up a an agreement for a lesser term
because it gave the new organization no
financial security with which to operate
and look at drawing in external
funding and opportunities and that's
position remains the same
so through our negotiations with the
button of biddeford now we've
we've again established that for uh
purposes of mpo status and other funding
a longer-term arrangement is much better
and much more financially beneficial for
us as a council because
it means that the trust does have access
to
additional funding that we don't
necessarily have surroundings having a
cup of tea delivered getting the
important business done
um marvelous yeah absolutely so
so like i say it it it's never been the
case
i mean i've written i think every report
presented every
report about this matter and never once
has
the trust will be self-sustaining
financially after five years
past my lips or been written by my pen
so it's never been an aspiration of ours
it's never been intended that way what
we intended to do was set up
a a if you like a fulfillment vehicle
was a word that was used earlier on when
i was when we were discussing this
to deliver what we need to deliver to
look after our assets
to make our collections publicly
available
in a much more efficient way than we
could do ourselves and that's what's
been achieved
so we it's initially set out on a an
agreement where it's costing us around
200 000 pounds a year to do this
to run this facility not as well as it's
being run now i might add
ourselves um it next year it will cost a
hundred and forty thousand pounds under
this arrangement
last year in this financial year has
cost 169
000 pounds so it this constitutes
a budgeted for saving
and a service improvement and that's why
i was happy to recommend it teacher
and have happy to recommend it to cnr
yeah so
that that's that's basically their
background in a nutshell yeah
thank you that was a good speech sean
kearney
no problem thank you very much right uh
chancellor tony
yes thank you chair yeah well
just go back to what cheryl said uh sir
uh honking um you know i think we are
forgetting something here
that the burton art gallery which i'm a
great fan of actually i think it is one
of our
great achievements um you know we look
we have to look further afield say down
into 10 times to take gallery for
anything else like
it so i mean it's very we're very
fortunate to have something like this
but
they do the burton art gallery do
provide service
as well for torres torridge district
council
because they hold a lot of our artifacts
and things like that
whereas if we didn't have the burden we
would have to do that
and i i think i'm right in saying if
sean
can come back as well that that would
cost us probably just as much as we're
putting into it
so you know the burton art gallery
to be self-sufficient they are providing
a service for us
and i think we should remember that the
only thing i'd like to say
and like to
get right i think that uh we have
some uh simple reports coming back from
the burton art gallery
every quarter um you know reports that
we can all understand and we can all
um look at their finances in detail
uh perhaps they could come back to this
committee
with with those reports every quarter
chair yeah that would be fine
that would be fine i i the thing is i i
don't agree with
with sean by leaving it for three years
i think
if we're gonna do this we we should look
at it every year
uh to so that we can keep keep keep our
tabs on it keep up to date and
everything else with it
but you know not not leave it for three
years then to start to look
what we're going to do after the next
two or three years no
am i able to come in here
am i able to come in here chair you are
on my list now
um there's a couple of things that
i think is important for the committee
first of all
coming back on a point of of counselor
newton's
i absolutely support that that clause
should be very clear it is very clear
i'm looking at it right now in front of
me it's two lines
um i'm a business person too to those
committee
and any business person would not want
to get into
a financial commitment of something
that's discretionary
only to find that whatever happens in
the next few years
then uh there is no um exit strategy
so um as i said last presentation
um as the board of trustees we take our
responsibilities
very very seriously you know the work
that the board of trustees
does and the hours that it commits to
those i suppose a simple way of looking
at that is it replaces
the work that the officers did at the
time when it was run by that
but uh in terms of the time that's put
aside that the trustees have
put that time and hours in to make the
but to get the burden into the
the good shape that you saw in that in
that presentation
so that that was the first thing that
you know you've got my absolute
commitment
counselor newton and all of you have uh
to those on that point because that's
just good business practice
the second point on the discussions
about whether it's three
one uh to those or uh to those whatever
years
the really important things in the
presentation and i know that this
committee has also had that
if you look at the slides the pie charts
that were on pages 11 and 12
those are actually key because
the reason that we're able to say that
we can operate potentially for the next
five years on this level and continue to
do what we want to do
is because we are becoming attractive to
more
external funding but the key thing on
attracting external funding of any
degree
is having some longevity
and trust to those of that so the the
big example to those
for this is as ian danby said on the
last presentation
when we come to reapply to the national
portfolio organization
are those again we will be going in for
significantly more funding than we
currently currently get
and on slide 12 you will see that as how
that future in
income model and to those potentially
kind might work
however however if there is
a statement and to those um
that um from yourselves
that you're only interested in
um a one-year two-year three-year
agreement for managing the assets that
we can do
those organizations particularly the big
ones are just
not interested in it so
potentially for example when the burton
for those of you those who remember were
looking um
potentially when there was a proposal
that the library would become part of
the burton building and extension
applications for external funding for
capital of four or five million pounds
you know nobody is going to look at that
if they're not quite sure whether
there's a
whether a funding agreement of those is
going to end after 12 months
so the beauty of what we're proposing to
those is
is it allows the charity to go out and
grow
it allows it aspirationally to move in
the direction that it showed in terms of
getting the balance portfolio
it allows it releases the hours of work
and to those that the officers did and
it was a very time consuming process as
many of you that those have been around
and it gives you that safety net you
know that whatever
whatever we're all facing and to those
either way
then there's an open door for discussion
and exit to those strategy
i you know it just seems every way
around to those a win-win to me
and to this but you would find
yourselves in a worse
situation um in terms of
uh you know those anything broadly or to
those less than five years which
you know i think um again just going
back to the presentation
on the earlier slide of external
endorsements
on slide nine we extrapolated the
statement
from the artistic assessment by arts
council which is essentially an audit
councillors to those and you will see
that this says the burden does more than
many others are much less
we would be interested in burton
applying for more funds in the next
round of
rpo however it would be affected by a
significant reduction in funds from
torridge
now clearly a hundred and forty
seventeen and a half percent uh decrease
is is a significant
to those funding but if if we as the
trustees and ian dunby as the director
can show our confidence
in being able to work our programme to
that they are likely to accept that
thank you chair okay yeah julie why are
you while you're on
yes um i was absolutely intrigued
about two hundred thousand football
short yes i i how do you measure that
a door counters chair on every door
so we take it we have we have the
capacity to make
um an hourly count if we wish to
or a daily count so there are door
counters because
um a lot of the exhibitions for example
um they would want to know what the
footfall is into the certain exhibitions
so uh so there would be door counters on
the door when you go
in and to those and we can also see
those general entrances the number of
people who go into the museum or go into
it into an
everyday one it just surprises me
because
i'm sure it does chair it really does
surprise me judith because
rose rosemoor in 2018
only got 234 000 right
i just find it difficult to understand
that you had 200
000 football last year in in the burton
art gallery
is it being measured properly uh yes yes
i know a few years ago it was measured
when
i think you you said we'd you had 20
000 but then you found that they were
measuring it
counting it going in and out so you know
i don't know
i just i'm just very very surprised
that's all
anyway um i'll come back on that chair i
am glad that you're surprised
um i would be a rather foolish chair of
trustees if i was um to be
presenting to this committee or anyone
and to external funding bodies
numbers that i didn't think that could
be
adequately organized and audited i'm not
sure whether 20 000
councillor watson it's not a number i i
i yeah
well it's 20 something thousand i think
it wasn't exact
i only rounded it to because i can't
remember the exact amount
uh anyway we'll move on in ian arpa
where are you
i'm here thanks chair obviously i was
beginning of the art gallery
and this is an organization i support
wholeheartedly
however i do agree with counseling you
and i think judas actually answered my
question
that we really ought to review this on
an annual basis
and the other thing the committee ought
to remember as well is under the deeds
i believe that we're not allowed to
charge for entry into the burden itself
so therefore we are always going to have
have
some in one form or another so it's
going to be very very long term
however what i would say as well is some
of the comments that have come forward
is that
perhaps the farther reaches of the uh of
torridge
are not seeing any benefit from the
burton and perhaps the burton could do
more outwork with the
with those sort of things with the
schools and with the communities
i think that's about it oh the other
thing is well sean
with these service agreements do we have
any targets and goals
that we actually set for the uh the
burton on an annual basis
thank you okay do you want to answer
that sean
yes of course yeah yeah so this is this
yeah i can answer that and
counselor inches inquiries earlier on
actually all in the same
way so um in within
funding agreement we set out very
clearly what we expect
to be provided by the button of
biddeford for our
financial contribution there are
a number of um key performance
indicators that we ask for reports back
on and quarterly they are reported back
to us
they're contributed within the members
bulletin and and at least
on an annual basis uh external scrutiny
provide the scrutiny for this
service so because it's a grant or a
funding agreement with an external
body external scrutiny provide the
scrutiny
so yes i mean i i'm we can work on the
format
of how um things are reported back in if
i'm sure judith and ian i mean they've
already talked to me about that before
now but i'm sure that's a flexible
thing we can work on how uh the format
the the
what we look for is set out in the
service and funding agreement
and then coming back to mr harper's
point on the outreach
um actually the burden i think made some
great strides
in getting out to the parishes last year
if you remember they bought the
horse box and were going out and about
to extend the reach
to the the far-flung parts of the
district um and the feedback from that
was very positive i'm sure judith can
add to this
obviously um with the last six months
have been incredibly difficult because
nobody's been able to go anywhere so
that that momentum might have been lost
a little but i'm sure there's an
intention to rebuild that
do you want to answer that judy
hello
i apologize i've just unmuted myself
uh yes um outreach is a key part of the
strategy
and again uh just picking up on uh mr
harper's
words if you if i take you to slide six
uh you will see the significant
developments that have been
made in education and outreach since the
formation of the charity
um the horse box is only one element of
that
i think in terms of reaching mr harper's
quite right you know there are probably
some of your communities that we don't
reach
but there's also something where we
would welcome those opportunities from
you
you know it's it's a pretty small team
in the burton there are only two
full-time members of staff
and in your communities if you know
things that we don't know of where for
example that horse box could be you
ian would be absolutely delighted you
know those of you who know me and if
he never says no to any of those
opportunity
the other thing just to add about
outreach which had been put on hold
because of covid but we had started to
develop some outreach work
to take place in care homes um or in
hospices
and that has just had to be put on hold
you know for obvious reasons
uh of isolation of that and that was a a
request that came to us from councillor
pennington
um at last year's through the external
overview and scrutiny
and also at the agm thank you chair
okay peter
ames thank you
yeah i'm very much in support of the
burton having visited it
for many years now it's just small
points really about
um it's been raised about scrutinizing
the burton and how it's performing i
was looking at these pie charts here
about what the income that
comes into the burton and i can't i
can't quite see any difference in the
from 2016 and 2020 with the cafe rental
um workshop income and sharp income
but perhaps i'm wrong i mean i can't see
these little squares very easily if it
seems to me some of the
these these are these segments haven't
really shifted
over four years so i just wonder if
judith could say
anything about it
um so you're looking at uh you're saying
that the segments haven't
haven't shifted um so uh between 16 17
20 21 so i'll talk about the there's the
cafe so
uh the cafe is operates as a concession
so they have
uh a renewable agreement with us
um and uh there is a fixed rental income
and um there are opportunities for
negotiation until there's renegotiation
of that but that is
as a subcontract
i think i mentioned at the previous
committee at those meetings i brought
your attention
donations and legacies because you would
actually see that there had been
potentially that there'd been a downward
shift to those in that and that was
because in the first year of the charity
um we were fortunate enough to get a
legacy to receive a legacy
clearly these things aren't planned you
know you don't know if they're going to
be there and
how much they're going to be for um but
the other thing that i think is
important to draw to attention that
donations
in the more traditional way that we may
all know
of um small change in a box
or money that's put in to those is that
is very much
not just at the burton through all of
museums organizations
an income source that is that is moving
uh that is very much
um moving downwards
we do get some income onto those through
uh through website donations
and uh we will be installing some
contactless payments as well
um councillor homes if there's any other
section that i can
um draw if i can answer that question uh
the eight the ace funding will stay
static for the period
of the mpo agreement um but that is the
the that is the uh the big area that
will be our growth
um you know subject to you uh endorsing
um uh the uh proposal today
so thank you very much yeah it's really
the the three things i mentioned you
know that
i was a bit surprised that the rental
hasn't gone up for the cafe
and that the shop hasn't seemingly
earned any more money
there's two things i think it's a lovely
shop at the burton beautiful things but
i always feel they're a little bit on
the pricey side but there we are that's
your that's your decision
it isn't that the shop hasn't earned any
any more money
remember these these segments don't show
real sums
these are in a percentage
of that agreement but the you will see
that the
through the quarterly report we we uh
report year on year the
um retail performance so you would be
able to see the increases
through the quarterly reports in the
members bulletin
okay thank you very much judith um
if i could just come back before stephen
before stephen comes in
you really need to to get out to down my
neck of the woods
because well uh down oldsworthy
clawton broadwood would you sent giles
on the east
ash water because they don't really know
you
at all right and this is a fact
it's not it's i've done some research
over these last few weeks
and and they haven't got a clue really
who you are
the odd two or three yeah but being once
and won't go bother going again you need
to do something if you're going to do
that
outreach i know that the school down in
saint giles
uh i think you sent him an email or
somebody
sorry not probably not you but uh
the bet and sent an email to him uh and
it why why can't you pay a visit to the
school
um and they don't they don't really know
too much about you at all
it's about an art gallery well um chairs
uh thank you for that feedback it sounds
as if we've got a date
um uh in which uh that we should
you know that we can work on to build on
some of these other these other areas
i'm not i i'm not the person to be able
to say how often
you understand you know and whether they
have been approached that would be
ian danby's but i'll make sure that
that's a taken away point thank you
yeah i mean i don't know whether you've
been to oldsworthy or not but
also with the ambulance parish council
there was only one of them
knew who you were not particularly
youtubers
don't mean that's all right am i talking
about the book i don't mind it being
that way
you know but anyway
stephen dengate thank you chair um
it's really just uh to go on councillor
haynes
and and come back on judith judith um
thank you for the
talk for the funding model i think you
know you have done well to start
moving it and i think it's it's going in
the right
direction but i would just really
encourage you to try and look at the
individual donations
because it's not just the fact that
there is um a strong support
for burton that you probably would pick
up you know small donations and it's
good that you're doing contactless
but it does bring engagement with the
people um
and it creates those relationships
it's not just about the receiving is
it's the giving the person giving that
gets the benefit as well
as the burden receiving their donation
so i would just encourage you because
you're very grant dependent so if
if grants do become more pressured
you'll be needing to look to other areas
of funding
individuals might serve you well in the
future
[Music]
that's all thanks all right okay
cheryl thank you um i think we've had
plenty of scrutiny of this now
and i'd like to recommend that we keep
the cnr decision
seconded thank you
okay fine
anybody else
i was prepared to see that we looked at
the burden every year
not i'd and i don't mean don't give them
a
um an agreement for five years but at
least
come back every year to to have
a discussion like this with the burden
they do come back to external
um yeah absolutely on external with with
it
yeah pete that but that pete that's
sean has said that is in the agreement
that that
there is a there is a a um
there's a commitment over the five-year
period
but there is a technical clause
that judith has acknowledged that allows
in in in a moment of extremis or
or major yeah danger priorities
yeah there is a get out of jail clause
which allows us to
revisit on an annual basis
is that right
so [ __ ] i'll read you the exact clause
if you like
uh it's it isn't it no no it's a it's a
two it's a two-liner as judith said so
it won't take long
it says uh the title of the clause is
the party's obligations
and it reads the council agrees to make
the payments specified in part three
and part three sets out the 140 years
for
five years uh for a duration of five
years
covering and then the year sorry i've
skipped to the wrong says the council
agrees to make the payment specified in
part three of this agreement
financial and resourcing arrangements
subject to overriding budgetary
constraint
now that that gives you flexibility not
just on an annual basis
but actually flexibility as and when you
know we have to be reasonable right
on a whim um but it you know
there is provision to look at this
whenever we require
what we may require to look at it casey
is that right
yeah yeah if it says um i wasn't
involved in the working groups for the
the trust at all
um but i was involved in the in the
the transfer of the trust and preparing
the legal documents and in
some respects it was kind of helpful
that i didn't know the background
because i came at the documentation
um in a manner of protecting torridge as
opposed to actually knowing all the
background and i
um i've got a great deal of respect for
judith but as judith will know that was
it got quite heated on occasions when we
were doing
that paperwork um because i i had
exactly the same concerns as members are
raising today
in terms of the funding going forward um
because i i felt five years and the sums
of money involved um
you know if the situation changed your
torment situation changed we could be in
quite a difficult situation
um and that's why those clauses were put
in there
although obviously judith had explained
and the rest of the trust had explained
and they do need that security and for
the business going forward
and then it also helped them tap into
other funding
um my understanding of the transfer to
the trust
was one because they were doing a could
do a better job
of it than torridge and secondly
um the trust would be able to access
funds that torridge as a council
weren't able to access so it opened up
greater doors
um but that's why the clause is in there
um subject to over
riding budgetary constraints because um
i wanted it in there to protect horridge
and the trust had agreed to that so yes
if our
financial situation changed dramatically
um then yes we we have got to get out
crawls out of the agreement
but hopefully the five-year agreement
with that
gives the trust enough stability to be
able to carry on going forward
and um obtain the overall elements of
funding going forward
okay thanks stacey okay that's oh mr
pennington
come on phillip yeah thank you chair
yeah just to
i think sometimes we're in danger of um
checking the baby out with the bath
water
sorry cheryl thinking about your noodles
in motion at full council next monday
but uh
there we are um you just took the
direction of travel with children
grand plus back pre-2016
um i look at some of the displays that's
been there i've not been a regular
attender
but i've gone down four or five times a
year and to have a figure of 140
000 pound a year now i think it's a good
deal you've got braces and belt
i was lead member for culture um for
three years of the previous four-year
administration
you've also all got to ask your question
if you don't fund it what are you going
to do with the building
so there's a there's a negative aspect
here that nobody's actually asked that
question
so i think you've got a really good deal
and cnr were 10
nil i mean it's a it was a real
endorsement
of the work that sean and the team
stacey have done there
and i just think it'd be a real shame if
you turn this back
now um um it's a good deal
um you get the recorded reports it's all
in place
um and you can make your feedback to ian
and judith as you want to you've got
good relationships there um don't rock
the boat thank you for
allowing me to speak chair yeah no
problem phillip
simon yeah i'd just say i'm content
chair
yeah okay after this meeting that's why
am i
okay have we got a proposal in a second
for anything
i can't remember now it's it's been
going on that long okay you have you've
got a proposal
a proposal from councillor carl hunking
and seconded by council
langford um to retain the decision
taken by cnr okay but
this clause will be in it the agreement
the agreement
stacy yeah that clause is in it it will
be in
in the new agreement i'm sure judith's
happy with that it'll remain the same
um i don't i don't think you have to
actually go to the vote on this because
if you
if you're not going to make a
recommendation to cnr
um and cnar's decision will stand that
that
that that's it you need do nothing
hypothetically wouldn't it be great
the 200 000 people that come across your
door
if they'd all give a quid a piece
wouldn't it be nice
i'd be delighted to chair yeah is there
no way that
is there no way that you could charge in
the place sean
john
tronar mute sorry chair not that i'm
aware of it i don't
i don't believe i think there was a
covenant to say that we're not allowed
to charge for entry so
um yeah i guess that's not possible i
i know that um the the uh the charity
have been looking at how they can
get more from sort of donations and
whether the electronic payments and
things like that so
that it's under active investigation but
i don't think we can charge people to go
through the door
although like judy said i'm sure she'd
love to yeah and
don't don't you think it would be nice
that we could try and get rid of that
covenant as well
i think that's one of the benefits
though because it's open to everybody
regardless of background
yeah but i mean yeah that's fine cheryl
but people don't survive without money
and you know these places don't survive
and look at
look at the plow i mean
you know it is six or one and after
doesn't the other really anyway
we'll have a vote on we will have a vote
as to
whether we don't send anything at all
back to
to take to cnr and we'd just go with
cnr's recommendation
you don't need to vote
sorry don't need to vote do we i thought
stacy just said we didn't need to
did you say that city yeah if you're not
proposing anything
new to cnr and there's no new
recommendations and
and members are content with cnr's
decision then cnn's decision
will stand you don't need to vote on on
that journey okay every member
com you know content with senior's
decision
demo you don't you don't count
everybody content yes mr tone
yeah yeah yeah yes sure yes chair
yeah okay all right then
okay there thanks for coming judith uh
count uh chair can i say one thing
as well as thank you yeah thank you
um i'm leaving this meeting uh not uh
um not only very happy because you've
endorsed that
but personally chair i've just heard you
say something that never i thought in my
lifetime i would hear you say
and i've even written it down chair so
this has said after this meeting you too
are content
and and i think that you and i know well
know
each other well enough to know that um
this is sometimes a challenging topic
for you but i would just like to say
thank you for being
open-minded to those districts that's
what this meeting's all about
um you know it doesn't matter about my
my personal views
it's what the rest of the committee come
up with you know
and it's true you know you know i i've
i've been against this for a long time
but
you know i i well i know that council of
watson you've told me but now i can no
longer use that expression
some of the members that have said that
have said
people have heard me said that if i turn
councillor watson's view around it's
like turning titanic round before it
hits the iceberg
so i can now no longer use that
expression because it seems that i have
actually oh
hey come on do this do this
don't don't go too far all right
i'll lose my street cred man
thank you chair thank you all right
anyway
gaslers thank you very much you can
leave if you want judith it's up to you
hello
thank you all right okay we're nearly
finished now anyway i'll stay on for the
fun
oh yeah okay
so we've done that consideration of the
forward plan
page 50
what we got on for november
we we've got items brought where are we
items brought forward uh cat story tony
did you want to say something
where is it thank you chair no i was
just going to make a suggestion for the
forward plan
right well this last year has been quite
interesting and
we have worked differently on the
council you know we've had um
people staff working from home yeah
we've had
doom meetings and all that sort of thing
and i just thought that we could have a
look at
how that's worked for the council over
the last six
since since march there must have been
you know working from home for our staff
perhaps that's something we can carry on
with after the
pandemic yeah that may be something we
want to look into
because it may be saving us money also
also working groups for counsellors
perhaps we should have them by
zoom meetings i mean zoom meetings for
all our council meetings
since march must have saved us a lot of
money in
in expenses especially for you
sheriff coming for yeah too right i'm
quite happy doing this
that's perhaps we can just look at all
this sort of like
meetings by zoom and um and
working from home for our staff because
if we have
staff working from home our perhaps the
office space
needn't be so much we we don't need the
use of softer space we could move the
bed now to the bed and then put it in
riverbank
yeah well there's all sorts of um things
that we could do
and it's it's flagged up a lot of new
things for us i think this pandemic
and it's not all been bad does it you
know
working from home for a lot of people
has been it may be good it may be bad i
don't know
but but then again you just have to to
sort out who didn't want it and who does
want it
well perhaps perhaps we could have some
sort of report for the officers to say
how it has you know panned out in the
last
i don't know seven months eight months
or more yeah
yeah i think we'll leave it until 2023
because
i think we've still got this until then
haven't we well but there yeah
we can do that i'll i'll talk to steve
and sean yeah
yeah and and we'll we'll try and come up
with some sort of thing like for
to to do that yeah yeah i'd be
interested it would be very interesting
i would support that but very strongly i
think that's a very good idea
yeah and all of business and industry is
doing that
now uh everybody is reviewing
how they work where savings can be made
where work-life balance can be improved
etc and i think that's a very good i
think that's a very good idea
yeah brilliant yeah well done tony
and well let's have a look then okay
we'll put that on somewhere
mary mary
mary yes yes chair i have right okay
don't know when you want it though yeah
um
well the november meeting is
we've got the qbr2
and any items brought forward from qbr
one
and real treasure and investment options
everybody happy with that
don't all speak at once
we could bring it forward you know sort
of no later than the march meeting
because that's
that'll be 12 months since we've since
we started all this
thing isn't it the march meet
every 12 months yeah so
we should do it for the march meeting
perhaps that will be appropriate time
chair
might be we got the revenue budget and
capital program on that
on the march meeting yeah yeah
december yeah
december because we've got a good oh no
yeah december meeting we've got the qbr
training
and we could do it do we could do it
with that yeah yeah
i'll find chair yeah okay right
okay that's where it's going to go then
mary there
anything else
no okay
so i'll exclude the public now
so dermot can leave for sure in part of
the public
all right um that's it then
thank you all for coming and i hope
everybody on youtube
have had a good time and we will
sort out for when we have in the next
one okay
meeting closes at
15 i don't know 45
4